[PIANO PLAYING]
These are the words of
women asking for help.
They say they've been falsely
jailed in Tapachula a city
in the Mexican state of Chiapas.
They've been accused
of human trafficking.
A serious crime with a maximum
penalty of 30 years in prison.
Human trafficking in Mexico
is said to be a $150 billion
business-- with profits
finding their way
into the pockets of the
country's biggest cartels.
Mexico recently passed
a comprehensive reform
of their anti-trafficking laws
insuring harsher penalties
for those found guilty.
The new focus on
human trafficking
has increased convictions
and sentences,
which is something Mexico
is touting as a success.
But here in Chiapas,
those numbers
don't tell the entire story.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
That is Luis Villagran.
He is an outspoken
opponent of the way
human trafficking is fought
in Mexico and for good reason.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
Luis's false conviction
shed some light
on how Chiapas is
their successes.
According to Luis, of
those 60 traffickers who
were convicted and sentenced,
10 of them were eventually freed
and three of them were
completely exonerated.
These are the people
Luis has been fighting
for-- the innocent ones.
Women like Santa
Maria Rosales who
came to Mexico from Honduras--
fleeing violence and gangs.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
Santa Maria was arrested in
her home along with her brother
and cousin and was sentenced
to six years in prison
for human trafficking.
That's based on accusations
from witnesses who never even
showed up to her trial.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
Once in prison,
Santa Maria realized
her case wasn't unique.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
So Santa Maria decided
to help herself.
She and two other inmates
went on a hunger strike.
This helped shed
light on their cases
and they were eventually freed.
And before she left,
she made a pledge
to the innocent women
she was leaving behind.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
And she continues to fight
along with Luis and others.
They're speaking to
anyone who will listen.
They protest outside
the jail that
still holds innocent women.
And they won't stop
until there's justice.
Yes, human trafficking
is a major problem.
And yes, the Mexican
government should
be doing something about it.
But according to
Luis, they're unfairly
targeting migrant women.
Women who have
done nothing wrong.
Women were forced
to sign confessions
they don't understand.
Women who because of
where they're from
are already looked down
upon and stigmatized.
And if the Mexican government
is inflating their numbers
for PR purposes, to make it
seem like the streets are being
cleaned up, that only makes the
problem of human trafficking
worse.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
Mexico is not the only
country to be accused
of jailing the innocent.
Click here now to watch our
video on the innocent people
the United States
has put on death row.
Or click here to see how
America is using their prison
population as slave labor.
Inmates can be forced to work
as long as they're deemed fit
and can be punished
if they don't.
Including-- in some cases--
with solitary confinement.
And as always, please
subscribe to this channel
to make sure you get
all our new videos.
And thanks for watching.